raccoons oh get the they really i feel
like kind of get the
they get looked at i feel like as mother
nature's kind of hitman a little bit
they really have come into their own as
being just
burglars you know like i think every
time you see them they look so
guilty they look like they they're they
call them a bad new abandon they have
that kind of a mask on them
i mean they when they see our houses or
your house they just see a tree
they see you know every you know the
neighborhoods and subdivisions are
tearing down more woods and more
environment to
build the houses so they're running out
of places and they don't have really
their main predators man
wow and so they when they look at your
house just like any of these animals
they just see a
they just see a big tree a funny looking
tree you know they can climb right up
the siding right up a down spout and
they'll find a way in and they'll make
they'll make your home their home
so they just see their how your house is
a tree really that's yeah i mean that's
what they see it is you know just
just a different type of structure they
want to be the
the female raccoons they want to be up
high they want you know
if they're not like a cavity of a tree
it's where they know would be in the
nature
because they want it they want to be up
high so when they have their young
they're away from predators
they're away from things that could hurt
their babies one of their main
one their main concerns when they're
having their babies is male raccoons
another one of mother nature's things is
a male raccoon will search out to female
and kill those babies to make her come
into heat again which is
mother nature another cruel way of
mother nature it's
it's just a cycle just it's just mother
nature and so
the mama raccoons sal raccoons what we
come they'll they'll go
they get hide up in the attics and
that's they'll make their dens trying to
keep away from everything else and the
male raccoons
so even there could it even be the own
male that knocked them up
i mean it could be oh my god dude
it sounds like a damn john grisham i
mean it it's possible some of the
one technique that we use um eviction
fluid
which is mainly raccoon piss and
you can take it i'm not a big fan of it
because i like to catch the raccoon and
remove it no i've removed it out of your
house but you can take eviction fluid
and put around their entry hole and in
the attic
and the female raccoon will think
there's a male present
and take her babies and shy guy there
okay so you mean if you want to get her
out of there yeah some some places they
if you use like all humane you know no
trapping
they can use eviction fluid and that
that some that can make the female think
there's a male present and she'll get
her babies and get out
but you still have there's a raccoon
there right he's going to go somewhere
else it's going to be somebody else's
problem
i mean i like to trap him and get rid of
it that way i can tell the customer hey
we got
i've got mama i got five kits out of
your attic and
sealed up and we're good to go and we
got yeah we got the problem solved
otherwise you just
once you put that piss down there you
they're just looking they're you just
you're scaring them off you don't know
where you're scaring them to yeah we
haven't really solved the problem
they can they'll either leave or they'll
just go even deeper
you just carry in the one yeah you
haven't really solved the problem now
what about this uh
i want to get back a little bit to this
i mean it's almost like a
shakespeare story that the so the the
female
can have children have babies raccoon
can have babies and a man raccoon
will come and kill the babies while
they're being born
well after she has after she has them
will
the male raccoon eat them or just kill
them he usually just kills them
okay kill him and then kill him just so
the female will go back in the heat so
then he can get laid basically
yeah i mean yeah you can put it at that
i mean it's not the only all
a lot of animals do it uh lions you know
the they'll kill the cubs
you know the other animals like it'll
kill their offspring or
the offspring it just hurts me man to
make her to make him come back in the
heat so that's
it just hurts my feelings i mean that's
not i i don't come across that very
often but i mean
i've found it where i'll come do an
attic inspection
and just find a blood bath you know just
a little young
i mean they'll catch i mean size of the
the pop can
and just be ripped open just you know
horrible where the male raccoons come in
and kill them all
right i mean it happens you don't see it
very often which i don't see it very
often
it's like the people may it's like the
first forest eight kind of
yeah you know it's something like i said
mother nature's cool sometimes
how are they not a bigger problem it
seems like they're after sex you're
saying they're doing sex in the attic
and they're
um you know they're willing to kill
children that get sex
and they're you know they're obviously
breaking into people's homes like
i see them in the recycling bin
constantly or i see music in the trash
and i'll see
you ever see that one weird raccoon
that's in the recycling bin it's like
what is he he's like he's reading in
there or something you know
but i'll see the ones in you know it's
like you'll go out at night here's what
i find fascinating you'll go out to a
rate you'll drive to a neighborhood
in a peaceful regular looking
neighborhood everything seems normal
and it's only three or four trees in the
dang neighborhood it wouldn't
if you if you asked everybody all day is
there any raccoons in this neighborhood
people put zero on the form and you come
by at about dang
12 40 i feel like or 11 15
p.m and you'll see them in little groups
of three just cruising alone man
it's like they they can hide so i mean
they hide right before your damn eyes it
seems like
so how are they not a bigger problem and
what kind of problem are they these
raccoons and you can be honest with me i
mean they're
they're my raccoon my raccoons every
year through my business it's getting
bigger and bigger yeah
i mean more it's getting to be more and
more of a problem i knew it like the
more we
build and go into the farmland
we're taking out their habitat they're
like i said the only natural real
predator is man
is a car and disease which they get
overcrowded like anything they'll get
disease will get in them
distemper or they get rabies and they'll
kill some of them off
but they are i mean a lot of people have
them and don't know the heaven
really you know you might if you're at a
house you might hear something every
once in a while and they're like oh
that's just
raccoon no big deal they don't come in
here and bother me in my living room
because i'll be in houses it'll in
addicts oh we just started hearing it
last week and it's obvious they've had
it for years
wow just some people just don't know it
i mean they're sneaky
they're sometimes quiet you got the
insulation in your attic and
they don't make a whole lot of noise you
know or you overlook it as something
else or
just don't want to know what just don't
want to know what it is
and are they flame retardant raccoons
can they are they are flammable animals
you know what i'm saying like they
they're their skin is so thick it seems
like they wouldn't be
in an attic it just seemed like a good
place for fire you know or something
like that i mean
they're actually they're very tough
creatures i've had um
i did had a one particular job this
spring early spring
or late winter and it took as a month
and three days for that caught four
raccoons have an attic
in a month and three days the final
raccoon came out
and what was he doing just hands up and
denied
they were juvenile young raccoon last
year's raccoons just denning
and just they're trap shy and won't you
know
they won't they won't come out i mean in
the summertime it's not unusual to have
a raccoon go
a week maybe two weeks in the summer and
an attic could be 140 degrees
i mean they're tough creatures stay in
there no food or water
no sometimes they can get water your air
conditioning will have condensation pan
they'll sip off that bastard they can
get a little bit of water off that snake
they're just so damn sneaky that's what
gets me you know they're just the damn
they're the real andy do friends of the
damn animal kingdom
you know what i'm saying they're wild
man is there any animal as sneaky
as a raccoon i mean let's put the crown
on the prince brother is there any
animal
as sneaky as a dang raccoon um
i gotta say bobcats there you go that's
i mean it's
i don't get the calls you know for you
know like they don't invade your homes
like a raccoon does but they're
they got to be pretty sneaky i mean i
would they're pretty sneaky um
rats i do a lot of rat work oh yeah they
can be a pretty sneaky so do i brother
they they're hard to get and they're
they're sometimes they're pretty big
challenge to get the rats they're pretty
sneaky though
they don't like change and you know you
mess with them they'll change the routes
and where they come in and they're
sneaky animal they're all kind of sneaky
you know but
those come to mind as being the most
sneaky to me there's a real fine line
from cute to pass didn't there yeah is
that real fine line baby raccoons are
adorable
i mean they're well they're so cute my
grandmother
didn't really like me and uh whenever
she died
or uh she was still alive but we didn't
get along well but um
the lady i remember this lady told me
one time my grandma didn't like me this
is her friend
her friend told me that and her friend
had a raccoon on him which told me
her friend kept a raccoon as a pet hope
you enjoyed that video
and you can watch another and you can
watch this one you can watch this one
different options different choices some
guy just brings you one option
not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one
you